merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues je
souhaite débuter mon intervention
hommage au peuple ukrainien qui fait
preuve d'un courage sans faille face à
l'inverse en russe qui a débuté le 24
février dernier et saluer la délégation
aujourd'hui présente pour assister au
débat de notre assemblée
le 21 septembre dernier le ministre
russe de la Défense a affirmé qu'il ne
combattait pas tant l'Ukraine que
l'Occident ce message très direct envoyé
aux Occidentaux ainsi que la nouvelle
loi sur la mobilisation partielle
décidée par Vladimir Poutine doivent
nous conduire à ne plus tergiverser sur
l'attitude que nous devons adopter
vis-à-vis du régime russe et des
sanctions que nous prenons contre lui
elle doit aussi nous conduire à un
profond questionnement sur notre
incapacité à trouver des alliés au sud
laissant ainsi l'opportunité au chef du
Kremlin de se présenter comme
l'hypothétique chef d'un axe non aligné
soudainement ressuscité en s'appuyant
notamment sur les échecs et manquement
de la France en Afrique
mais a-t-on déjà oublié que depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine
la Russie n'a en effet CC et peut-être
il y avons-nous une part de
responsabilité de s'éloigner des idéaux
démocratiques et de l'inaliénable droit
des peuples à disposer de même
elle s'affirme désormais comme une
autocratie impérialiste fondant son
pouvoir sur l'expansion militaire au
plan extérieur et sur un nationalisme
autoritaire écrasant les opposants et
les minorités sur le plan intérieur dont
l’invasion en Ukraine n'est que le
terrible et dernière avatar Poutine
réalise un rêve ainsi les rêves les plus
fous de l'extrême droite russe et
notamment de l'idéologue Alexandre
doughin partisan d'une Eurasie qui
écraserait l'Orient comme l'Occident mes
chers collègues il ne s'arrêtera plus
aussi et sans nul doute l'appui
militaire apportée aux forces
ukrainiennes à fonctionner il convient
donc de poursuivre et renforcer cet
effort madame la Première ministre
monsieur le ministre des armées les
canons César attendus par les Ukrainiens
ainsi que de nouvelles défenses
anti-aériennes à même de protéger les
populations les populations civiles des
bombardements doivent être livrées sans
plus attendre
mais nous devons aussi être beaucoup
plus clair sur notre positionnement
quant à la présence des entreprises
françaises restantes en Russie
notre économie ne doit pas devenir une
partie de l'arsenal du criminel de
guerre Vladimir Poutine au début de ce
conflit la France était le deuxième
investisseur étranger en Russie et les
entreprises françaises présentes sur ces
territoires se sont retrouvés confrontés
à un dilemme business ou éthique profit
ou humanisme argent ou principe dès le
début du mois de mars Emmanuel Macron a
choisi je cite de laisser les
entreprises décider pour elle-même
une analyse récente de la kiffe School
of économics révèle que les entreprises
françaises emploie 123642 personnes en
Russie
si la position de libre choix les sépare
le président de la République française
au début du conflit pouvait déjà
interroger elle n'est désormais plutôt
tenable l'appel à la mobilisation
partielle du 21 septembre nous oblige à
ouvrir les yeux sur le rôle que
pourraient désormais jouer c'est plus de
123 000 salariés dans le conflit
que dit en effet la loi russe sur cette
mobilisation elle oblige toutes les
organisations y compris les entreprises
internationales à procéder à
l'enregistrement militaire du personnel
si au moins un des employés est
susceptible d'effectuer son service
militaire
elles doivent également aider à remettre
les convocations de l’armée à leurs
employés assurer la livraison
d'équipements au point de rassemblement
ou aux unités militaires et fournir
moyens et renseignements
madame la Première ministre cette
nouvelle donne doit nous conduire à
établir une position claire sur le sujet
la semaine dernière le collective le
collectif biffor yukraine a lancé une
campagne accusant les sociétés
étrangères en Russie de participer à la
mobilisation criminelle du Kremlin en
aidant la conscription de soldats et à
l'équipement de l'armée nous ne pouvons
y rester insensible et la France doit
désormais être exemplaire dans ce
domaine fin août le président du Medef
Geoffroy route Bézieux prenait la
défense des entreprises françaises qui
ont choisi de maintenir des activités en
Russie affirmant que ce ne sont pas les
sanctions qui feront changer le régime
une étude de l'université de Yale paraît
au début du mois d'août dément pourtant
ses allégations ainsi que celle de
toutes ceux notamment à l'extrême droite
de cette hémicycle qui affirme que les
sanctions économiques infligées à
Vladimir Poutine aurait en effet
contribué à la prospérité de l'économie
russe
pour nos entreprises la situation a donc
en effet radicalement changé les chances
de voir certains de leurs certains de
leurs salariés partir faire la guerre
pour leur pays et de nous mettre dans
une position nous participerions à
l'effort de guerre russe à travers la
collaboration que la loi de mobilisation
partielle impose à toutes les
entreprises internationales et
manifestent le journal nemonde nous en
effet récemment appris qu'une ancienne
française qu'une ancienne française du
sud de la Russie a vu partir 150 de ses
employés au front si on en croit cet
article aucune entreprise hexagonale
n'en revanche était sommet de fournir
matériel ou assistance à l'armée mais
cette possibilité est bien prévu par la
loi par la loi russe alors madame la
Première ministre qu'en sera-t-il demain
vous savez de plus qu'il est très
difficile d'obtenir des informations en
provenance de la Russie tant ce régime
impose une forme de terreur qui pourrait
aussi bien nous en toucher nos
entreprises présentent là-bas et que
c'est donc peut-être déjà le cas une
dernière question se pose pour nous
entreprises quelle attitude adopter avec
leurs employés binationaux il serait 200
à être inscrit sur les listes
consulaires si la loi interdit d'envoyer
au service militaires des hommes
naturels naturalisés de plus de 27
aucune restriction semblable n'existe
quant à la mobilisation avons-nous envie
aujourd'hui de retrouver dans les rangs
russes des soldats possédant la
nationalité française que se
passerait-il si les Russes venait à
considérer que les binationaux
travaillant dans les entreprises
françaises sont avant tout de la chair à
canon mobilisables pour leur entreprise
de destruction madame la Première
ministre cette nouvelle situation va
nous amener à réagir il est urgent de
faire un état des lieux précis des
entreprises exerçant toujours une
activité sur le sol russe et de pouvoir
connaître leur niveau de participation
volontaire ou non à la mobilisation
décrétée par Vladimir Poutine merci à
vous